Smart Bless Mead. I watched Blair Witch last night. Oh my God. Why? October Fest. Okay, I saw it when I was, I've seen it a couple times, obviously, over the many, many years. I saw it, like, as a kid in the theater, thought it was straight up real and, like, you like, shat myself with fear.
Smart Bless Mead。我昨晚看了《女巫布莱尔》。天哪。为什么？十月啤酒节。好吧，我小时候看过，显然，在过去漫长的岁月里我看过好几次。我小时候在电影院看的，当时以为那是真的，吓得我屁滚尿流。
It's so funny to, like, grow up and look back at that. because they're such an improv troupe. Like, the acting is so, you know, really threads the line between naturalistic and just totally an improv troupe, you know? And, like, you can see it now as an adult. I don't know if I've ever seen it. Too scary.
长大后再回看那部电影真的很有趣。因为他们是一个即兴表演剧团。表演真的在自然主义和纯粹的即兴表演之间游走，你知道吗？作为一个成年人，你现在能看出来。我不知道我是否真的看过。太吓人了。
Oh, let's watch it, Jen. I can't. It's not real. We can get that out of the way. Imagine watching a scary movie and thinking you might be watching actual footage of a death in the woods. You know, remember how the girl
哦，我们一起看吧，珍。我不能。那不是真的。我们可以先排除这一点。想象一下看恐怖片时，以为自己看到的是森林里死亡的真实录像。你知道，还记得那个女孩吗？
had all the snot. I know. That's what everyone really latched on to. That was real, of course, that was real. Because she was so scared. They didn't have like a glycerin budget for sure. We all have a glycerin budget. It's like flying boogers.
鼻涕流个不停。我知道。那是每个人都真正关注的点。那当然是真的，那是真的。因为她太害怕了。他们肯定没有甘油预算。我们都有甘油预算。就像飞出来的鼻涕。
I need you go. I need you go. Gabe, I was thinking of you because I know you've only seen at this point one episode of task. And that's okay. Yeah. But I'm obsessed with it. And it's also given me an opportunity to bring out back my Delco accent, which I think I'm pretty.
我需要你走。我需要你走。盖比，我一直在想你，因为我知道到目前为止你只看了一集《Task》。没关系。是的。但我对它着迷了。它也给了我一个机会，让我找回了我的德尔科口音，我觉得我挺……
Delco accent. We'll get water ice. Delo County. You don't do it much. I realize. I never hear like even a jokey, Philly accent. I'm not saying you ever had that one. No, I would love to hear it on.
德尔科口音。我们会去买水冰。德尔科县。你平时不怎么说。我意识到。我甚至从来没听过哪怕是开玩笑的费城口音。我不是说你以前有过那种口音。不，我很想听听。
I have to put it on because I, you know, I outran it when I turned 19, moved to New York. said Wooder once got the look and then I became like a like a newscaster and you don't know where I'm from right oh yeah no no my brother says water my whole family says water and and I said slowly found other Philly and Delaware people who I can do the accent with and even Delaware brings it out a little bit like Delaware is almost the trapwork Delaware Delaware is huge Delaware Delaware but we should do one episode of the podcast be where accent you and I do the whole podcast in a Philly accent. I would love that.
我得装出来，因为你知道，我19岁搬到纽约后就改掉了。有一次说了“Wooder”（水），结果被盯着看，然后我就变得像个新闻播音员，你都不知道我是哪儿人，哦，是的，不，我哥哥说“water”，我全家都说“water”，然后我慢慢找到了其他费城和特拉华州的人，我可以和他们一起用那种口音，甚至特拉华州也会带出一点口音，就像特拉华州几乎是陷阱，特拉华州，特拉华州，但我们应该做一期播客，用费城口音，你和我用费城口音录完整期节目。我会很喜欢的。
What accent do I do? I don't know. You have like a couple hours to figure it out because we're getting started. You know what accent I'd like to have is like the one that they had on the show, The Nick? It's like, I'm old-fashioned and it was so good. Oh, that show ruled so much, just loved it. Do you still do coke injections in your penis, right? Me?
我该用什么口音？我不知道。你有几个小时的时间去想，因为我们要开始了。你知道我想要什么口音吗？就像他们在《尼克病院》里用的那种。就像，我很老派，那真的太棒了。哦，那部剧太棒了，我太喜欢了。你还在往阴茎里注射可卡因，对吧？我？
Yeah. Yeah. I don't, yeah. Otherwise, it's so sleepy. Oh, just because the FDA says it's eye medicine, it can't be penis medicine. Yeah. Get real. I have work to do.
是的。是的。我不，是的。不然的话，太困了。哦，就因为FDA说那是眼药，它就不能是阴茎药吗？是的。现实点吧。我还有工作要做。
Oh, my God. That show, it was so, did everything I needed something to do. Mm. You know, the weird stuff that they used to do that they thought was medical and then they would do it in like a big auditorium that seemed like a gym but also an amphitheater. And there would just be like the weirdest operation that was like really a dumb thing to do. and then they're all doing coke and they're having sex. Getting their nose eaten up by fucking infections. Yeah, some people missing a face.
天哪。那部剧，它太……我当时需要做点什么。嗯。你知道他们过去做的那些奇怪的事情，他们以为是医疗手段，然后他们会在一个大礼堂里做，看起来像个健身房，但也像个圆形剧场。然后就会有最奇怪的手术，那真的是一件很蠢的事情。然后他们都在吸可卡因，还在做爱。鼻子被该死的感染吃掉了。是的，有些人脸都没了。
Oh, my God. Yeah, some stuff. That was so good. Yeah, loved it. Pandem of the opera shit. For a second, I thought you were... Inside my penis. That's where the cocaine goes.
天哪。是的，有些东西。那太棒了。是的，很喜欢。歌剧魅影那档子事。有一秒钟，我以为你在……我的阴茎里。可卡因就是去那儿的。
Piness, penis. Right? That's the song? Yeah. Keep inside my penis. That's all it. Christine, my penis. The needle full of drugs
阴茎，阴茎。对吧？那是那首歌吗？是的。保持在我的阴茎里。就是这样。克里斯汀，我的阴茎。那根装满毒品的针。
Inside my cock Yeah Exactly Guys there's other This is when serious XM like Actually eats its own poison pill And is like we're done We're done
在我的鸡巴里。是的，没错。伙计们，还有别的。这就是天狼星卫星广播公司实际上吃了自己的毒药丸，然后说我们完了，我们完了。
We're done We can't do any more podcasts Not even any of any of them You owe Andrew Lloyd Weber Personally 40,000 pounds From that bed These three idiots get the wheel Get them out of there
我们完了。我们不能再做任何播客了。甚至连一个都不能。你个人欠安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯4万英镑。从那张床上。这三个白痴把方向盘拿走。把他们弄出去。
Excuse me Mr. Stern We're over We're over We're over, and that was good. We're over. Drink some water and get the heck out of your. Should I bring my I need you guys? I would love that.
打扰一下，斯特恩先生。我们结束了。我们结束了。我们结束了，那很好。我们结束了。喝点水，赶紧滚蛋。我应该带上我的“我需要你们”吗？我会很喜欢的。
Okay. Yeah. I got a text from our friend Lang, and it was like an Instagram story. What, no. No, an Instagram post. It looks like Mona Lisa Sapperstine. It was, in fact, in the scene. Your character from Parks and Rec, the character that I played, written by our friend Joe Mandy,
好的。是的。我收到了我们朋友兰的短信，那是一个Instagram故事。什么，不。不，是一个Instagram帖子。看起来像莫娜·丽莎·萨珀斯坦。事实上，那确实是在那个场景里。我在《公园与游憩》里的角色，我扮演的角色，是我们朋友乔·曼迪写的。
where Mona Lisa is saying money, please, and her father is, like, giving the money to her. But it was on the White House official Instagram. Like, this took me a second to be like, but what is this? It was on the White House official Instagram, and under the image of me as Mona Lisa saying, money please, it said illegal immigrants.
莫娜·丽莎在说“钱，拜托”，她父亲在给她钱。但它出现在了白宫的官方Instagram上。这让我愣了一秒，心想，这是什么？它出现在白宫的官方Instagram上，在我扮演莫娜·丽莎说“钱，拜托”的图片下方，写着“非法移民”。
And under Henry's character, Dr. Saprstein, it said, who's giving the money, it said Democrats. And I was like, oh, my God. Like, first of all, deeply upsetting on so many levels to make that type of a cruel joke
在亨利的角色萨珀斯坦医生下方，写着谁在给钱，写着“民主党人”。我当时想，天哪。首先，在这么多层面上制造这种残酷的笑话让人深感不安。
and then also to be the person that somehow has included that and it's used for just absolutely evil means but also to be like what should I do it's not like you know Dean Kane or something like a celebrity that I don't have
而且还要成为那个不知怎么就包含了这些内容并被用于绝对邪恶目的的人，但也要想我该怎么办，这不像你知道的迪恩·凯恩或其他什么我不认同其政治信仰的名人正在做这件事，如果我想的话，我可以决定说，嘿，伙计，因为它太可怕了，这是白宫，竟然是真正的白宫，这太疯狂了，你知道，如果你是我，显然你不是特朗普的选民，你不相信ICE正在做的事情，我想我们都会同意，而且我也觉得不难理解我的立场，我想你知道，嗯，你会怎么做，你觉得我该怎么做？哎呀，这太烂了，珍妮，我真的很抱歉，该死的。
the same political belief says is doing that and I can kind of if I want to decide to be like hey man because it's so scary it's the white house like to be actual white house that's psychotic you know like if you were me and obviously you're not a trump voter you don't believe in what ice is doing i think we would all agree and also i think like it wouldn't be hard to understand that that's where i'm coming from i think you know yeah um what would you do and what do you think i should do woof it's so shitty jenny i'm really sorry fucking
烂透了，这就像是……这也很令人羞辱，政府传达信息的方式竟然是这种奇怪、俗气的表情包。你的作品被完全、你知道，险恶的东西断章取义了。普通、善良、正常、理智的人不可能每秒钟都跳进去和这些疯子纠缠。这就是我给你的感觉，我知道你不使用社交媒体。我知道这件事已经引起了你的注意。而且我认为那个项目中有很多更愿意在社交媒体上发表声明的人，你真的不需要向Instagram上那些喜欢写留言的MAGA（让美国再次伟大）支持者敞开大门。
shitty that's like it's just like it's also like just like just humiliating that this is like the way the government does messaging is like in like weird, corny memes. Your work was taken out of context by like a completely, you know, sinister thing. Ordinary, like, nice, normal, sane people cannot jump in there every second with these cuckoos. And that was my sort of feeling to you is like, I know. you don't use your social media. I know that this has been brought to your attention. And I think there are plenty of people involved in that project who are more willing to be, like, on social media and making statements and whatever that you don't really, like, need to open the door to people who are MAGA on Instagram and like to write messages.
我只是觉得，那只会引来这些东西。我同意。我的意思是，首先，这是一个播客。你知道，是的，哦，该死，盖比，这不是戏剧，这是播客，不，哦，天哪，你不是……这是你，这是你的生活，我化了这么多妆，毫无理由，我戴着面具，我今天早上做了煎饼，为了化好妆，因为我不擅长这个，是的，我把巧克力豆弄得到处都是，那是阿米莉亚。
I'm just like, that's all that would come here. I agree. I mean, first of all, like, this is a podcast. you know like yeah oh shit Gabe this is not a play it's a podcast no oh my god you're not like this is you this is your life i'm wearing so much makeup for no reason i'm wearing a mask i made pancakes this morning to put on my makeup because i'm not very good at it yeah i got chocolate chips all over my average that's amelia
贝德利亚那档子事，马克斯做得很好，宝贝玉米，嗯，还有，阿米莉亚·贝德利亚，谈谈一些现在可能行不通的事情。但不管怎样，我当时想，你现在永远不能做阿米莉亚·贝德利亚了。在这种环境下你做不到。你甚至什么都做不了了。你甚至不能给玉米喂一小瓶叫“宝贝玉米”的奶。你甚至不能，他们会来找你的。所以我当时想的一件事是，等等，我觉得最糟糕的是这种……无意识的。
bedelia shit max is doing okay baby corn um And, Amelia Bidelia, talk about something that is, uh, it probably does not fly right now. But anyway, I, I was like, you can never do Amelia Bidelia now. You couldn't do it in this environment. You can't even do anything anymore. You can't even feed the corn a little bottle of milk called baby corn. You can't even, they'll come for you. So one thing I was thinking was like, wait, the worst thing I think is this, um, unconscious
假设，不知何故，我和可能每个人都被欺负得认为只有一种方式来回应这件事，而且你必须现在就做。否则，你就不是你，你就不坚持你的立场。所以你需要奇怪地跳进这些怪物的腹泻坑里，在他们的地盘上战斗。我有权等一等，考虑一下我想在哪里回应这件事，在一个竞技场或场地，或者其他什么地方，在一个讨论中，它不会立即变成一个腐败的空间。我同意你所说的一切，也就是说，这不应该是你的事。
assumption that somehow I and probably everyone has been kind of bullied into that it's like there's only one place to respond to this and you have to do it right now. Otherwise, you don't, you're not you and you don't stand for what you stand for. So you need to weirdly like get into the diarrhea pit with these monsters and fight on their turf. I have the right to like wait a sec and think about where I want to respond to this in an arena or a venue or whatever, in a discussion where it's just not immediately going to be a corrupt space. I agree with everything you're saying, which is like it shouldn't have to be your business to do it.
你不应该被迫降到他们的水平，等等。但我确实认为你内心深处真实的感觉，你可以快速发布并走出来，就是这太烂了。这确实很烂。而且它在很多方面都很烂。它烂是因为我们所说的所有原因，你的艺术被挪用到了残酷和这个议程中。但同时，那些创作好艺术，尤其是搞笑内容的人，他们确实在乎。他们把你的作品当作表情包，因为他们觉得它很有趣、有效，并且能很好地、令人难忘地传达一种情绪。
You shouldn't have to sing to their level, et cetera. But I do think how you feel authentically at its core, which you could quickly post and move through is just like, this sucks. It does suck. And it sucks in a bunch of different ways. It sucks for all the reasons we're saying that you're being co-opted, your arts being co-opted into cruelty and to this agenda. But also, like, people that make good art and especially funny stuff, they do care about. They're using your work as a meme because they think it's funny and effective and it communicates an emotion well and memorably.
而且，他们不能那样做。所以创作者说，不，这太烂了，然后截屏并继续前进。这太烂了。这太像2011年某人的Tumblr账户了，关于他们如何买公寓，做表情包，写着“当你锁定2%抵押贷款利率时的那种感觉”，然后配上一张《办公室》的图片什么的。这太臭了。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。我只是觉得Instagram不再适合我了。
And, like, they can't do that. And so the person who made it being like, nope, this sucks and just screencapping it and moving it on. Like, this just sucks. This is so 2011 someone's Tumblr account about how they're buying a condo and doing memes where they're like that feeling when you lock in 2% mortgage rate and then it's like a picture from the office or whatever. Like it stinks. It's so bad. It's so bad. Like I just, I don't feel that Instagram is the platform for me anymore.
我曾经确实觉得它适合。但对我来说，要诚实地说出任何正在进行的讨论，或者对某事的反驳，我实际上认为我想做的是我正在做的，也就是，你知道，完全可以叫我像个大喷射的混蛋，但把它放进我的创作工作中，不幸的是，这就是那个喷射的混蛋，这就是你的播客，我想说，我宁愿放一些非常简洁的真理，比如我他妈的讨厌这个，我觉得这很烂，我觉得那些人一点也不好笑，而且他们非常残忍。我宁愿把它放在一个讨论中，在那里我也不会被贬低。事实上，我是一个三人组，当我们有很棒的嘉宾时，即将变成四人组。来吧。我们谈谈它。我们也享受我们的生活，我们把困难的事情放在对话中。这实际上很好，我需要你们把我们的嘉宾也包括进来。所以当我们休息回来时，我们将听取……
I did feel like at one time. But like for me to be like honestly saying anything that is an ongoing discussion or like a. retort to something like I actually think that what I would like to do is what I'm doing which is like you know totally call me like a big like squirting douche but to like put it into my creative work which is this unfortunately this is the squirting douche this is your podcast to be like I'm I would rather place like the some very succinct truths which is like I fucking hate that I think it sucks I think those people aren't funny and that they're deeply cr rule. And I would rather put that in a discussion where also it's like, I'm not reduced down to anything. In fact, like, I'm in a three person about to become four when we have our wonderful guests. Come on. We talk about it. And we also enjoy our lives and we place difficult things in like conversations. This is actually a good, like I need you guys to include our guests with today. So when we're back to the break, we're going to get input from the
很棒的肖恩·海耶斯。肖恩·海耶斯。我们的爸爸之一。他是我们的爸爸之一。我们要向爸爸寻求帮助。所以我们马上回来，和肖恩一起。我需要你们。哦。
wonderful Mr. Sean Hayes. Sean Hayes. One of our dad does. He's one of our dad does. We're going to ask dad for help. So we'll be right back with Sean. I need you guys. Oh.
这是你们。这太令人兴奋了。你们是最棒的。我们能只说这个吗？你们是最棒的。好吧，太棒了。这就是我们所有的时间。你们所有的时间都结束了。
This is you guys. This is so exciting. You're the best. Can we just say that? You are the best. Well, great. And that's all our time. all of your time is over.
肖恩，我不知道你是否还记得，但我们，我，你，还有盖比，在2020年3月一起制作《Q-Force》。历史上美好的时光。我不记得这个了。一个强大的月份。但我记得就在我们不得不去……
Sean, I don't know if you remember this, but we, me, you, and Gabe were working together on Q-Force in March 2020. Beautiful time in history. I don't remember this. A powerful month. But I remember right before we had to go
远程制作节目，通过一个叫Zoom的我们从未听说过的应用程序，你当时正在设置这个麦克风装置，我想，在这个房间里，你说，我正要和朋友们开始这个播客，我们正在设置，这样我们就不用在同一个空间里了。我当时说，你把时间浪费在这个上面干什么？
remote to make the show over some app called Zoom we'd never heard of, you were setting up this like mic setup, I think, in this room and you're like, I'm about to start this podcast with friends and we're setting up so we don't have to be in the same space. And I was like, what are you wasting time on this for?
兄弟，我们正在为Netflix制作一部动画片。你不需要做这个。你不需要做播客，伙计。你做得很好。我知道。我知道。确实是。马利斯小姐就是从你们这些家伙那里诞生的，就像，我们已经做了20、25年的朋友了，差不多是这样。
Brother, we're making an animated show for Netflix. You don't need to do this. You don't need to do a podcast, buddy. You're doing fine. I know. I know. Really was. Miss Marlis was just born out of the, like you guys is like, we've been friends for 20, 25 years, something like that.
我们当时只是想，我们哪儿也去不了。所以让我们做这个，一起玩吧。他们当时说，哦，好吧，与其Zoom和闲逛，不如做个播客和闲逛。是的。然后两个人听，然后10个人，然后就像，有人要香波吗？你记得那个吗？你记得那些广告吗？我告诉了两个朋友，他们又告诉了两个朋友，以此类推。
And we're just like, we can't go anywhere. So let's just do this and hang out. And they were like, oh, well, let's, instead of zooming and hanging out, let's do a podcast and hang out. Yeah. And then two people listen and then 10 and then it's like, well, a balsam shampoo, anybody? Do you remember that? Do you remember those commercials? I told they told two friends and they told two friends and so on and so.
那是1970年代的一个老广告。是的。是香波。是香波。你知道80年代哪个广告真的让我想要吃掉肥皂，而且现在想到它还是这样吗？哦，我完全知道是哪一个。你觉得是哪一个？泡泡先生？
It's an old commercial from the 1970s. Yes. It's shampoo. It's shampoo. You know what commercial from the 80s literally made me want to eat the soap and still when I think about it? Oh, I know exactly the one. What do you think it was? Mr. Bubble?
不。爱尔兰之春。是的。爱尔兰之春？完全是。天哪。等等，为什么？它看起来太棒了。
No. Iris Spring. Yeah. Iron Spring? Totally. Oh my God. Wait, why? It just seems so good.
它确实很好。你还记得Gleem牙膏的广告吗？不。你记得Gleem吗？她把它倒过来拿。她说“meagle”。然后就像，不，是Gleem。对吧？
It was good. Do you remember the commercial for gleam toothpaste? No. Do you remember gleam? And she held it upside down. She's like meagle. And there's like, no, gleam. Right?
然后她舔了舔嘴唇，她说，哦，太恶心了。但我当时想，我会试试的。那是一个艺术性的广告。我希望有更多那样的东西，他们读错了，然后是的，他们对倒着读如何运作更俏皮，这实际上……并不会反转字母。
And then she, and then she licked her lips and she's like, oh, it was so gross. But I was like, I'll try it. That's an artistic commercial. I wish there was more stuff like that where they read it wrong and then yeah, and they're more playful with how reading upside down works, which actually. doesn't reverse the letters.
对。我们在救护车后面拍摄，因为一切都是反的。在救护车前面。好吧，我想说的一件事是，关于盖比小时候最可爱的事情之一。事实上，盖比，我昨天想到了你，因为我女儿问，为什么我不坐校车？我们住的地方离她学校只有四个街区。
Right. And we shoot it in the back of an ambulance because everything's backward. And on the front of an ambulance. Well, one thing I was going to say is, so one of the things that I think is one of the cutest things about Gabe when he was a little boy. Actually, Gabe, I thought about you yesterday because my daughter was like, why don't I take the school bus? And we live like four blocks from her school.
我说，我不知道。我现在甚至无法向你解释这个。你才四岁。但你不需要。你不需要。是的。校车就像一辆大车，肖恩，带孩子们去学校，但它也可以用于其他事情。
I was like, I don't know. I can't even explain this to right now. You're four. But you don't need to. You don't need to. Yeah. A bus is like a big car, Sean, that takes kids. kids to school, but it can be for other stuff.
我需要照片。所以校车经过了，我记得的是，盖比最喜欢的故事之一，就是他小时候，他在校车上。沿着校车的中间过道走，他绊得非常厉害，然后一路摔了下去，然后站起来说，超级格罗弗！那是我认为我的第一个笑话。笑话。超级什么？
I need pictures. So the bus went by, and what I remembered, which is one of my favorite stories from Gabe, is that when he was a little boy, he was on the school bus. Going down the center aisle of the school bus, and he tripped super hard and, like, fell like all the way down, and then got up and went, Super Grover! That was what I considered to be my first joke. joke. Super what?
超级格罗弗。他有像格罗弗和芝麻街那样的超级斗篷。是的。
Super Grover. He had like Grover and Sesame Street had like a super cape. Yeah.
超级格罗弗。当时的情况是我坐在座位上，校车猛地刹车，其他所有孩子都完全……
Super Grover. And what it was was I was sitting in my seat the bus braked super hard and every other child was totally
没事，但不知何故，我像火箭一样飞过过道，落在了校车前面。
fine but for some reason I like when flying like a rocket up the aisle landed at the front of the bus
每个人都看着我，好像在说他没事吧？我当时一定才五岁，我有那种机智说出“超级格罗弗”。
everyone was looking at me like is he okay? I must have been like five and I had the wherewithal to be like super grover
那对我来说是一个真正的喜剧胜利。人们笑了吗？人们笑了。对。我回家后还吹嘘了一番。
and I that was like a real triumph for me as a comedian. Did people laugh? People laughed. Right. And I came home and I bragged about it.
那是你的第一个笑话。之所以这不仅仅是我ADHD发作毁了整个播客，是因为我的第一个笑话之一是关于我在电视上看到的广告，我会无缘无故地走到成年人面前，举起手，把腋窝推出来说，如果你确定，就举起手。确定。哦，是的。我记得那个。
And it was your first joke. And the reason why this is not just me having like an ADHD flare up ruining the entire podcast is that one of my first jokes was about a commercial that I saw on TV and I would go up to like adults for no reason and raise my hand and push my armpit out and go, raise your hand if you're sure. Sure. Oh, yeah. I remember that.
我记得那个。我过去经常做那种事。是的，我当时想，当我做那个除臭剂动作时，每个人都他妈的爱死我了。我最好做这个。我高中时经常做一个段子……
I remember that. I used to do shit like that all the time. Yeah, and I was like, everyone fucking loves me when I do that deodorant thing. I better like do this. I used to do a bit in high school
我会背着背包，把它打开一点，这样当我走到楼梯顶端时，我会故意在楼梯顶端绊倒，我所有的书都会飞得到处都是。人们会觉得那是最好笑的事情。所以我被评为高年级最有可能……
where I would have a backpack on and I would open it just enough so that when I reached to the top of the stairs, I would on purpose trip on the top of the stairs and all my books would go flying everywhere. And people would think that was the funniest thing. So I was voted senior most likely to
在毕业典礼上绊倒的人。所以在2000人毕业的队伍里，有人对我说，做啊，做啊。我说，我想我要做了。所以我走上去，他说，他们说，肖恩·海耶斯。院长把毕业证书递给我。我故意绊倒了。每个人都站起来鼓掌。
trip at graduation. So in the line of the 2,000 people graduating, I had people like, do it, do it. I'm like, I think I'm going to do it. So I got up there and he goes, and they're like, Sean Hayes. And the dean hands me to my diploma. And I tripped and purposed. Everybody stood up and clapped.
天哪。我喜欢它。你有没有像橄榄球运动员练习时那样撞倒讲台，他们必须用力撞向那个东西？你知道我的意思吗？是的，完全正确。是的。就像他们侧面撞击它，从顶部把它刺穿，这就是你所想的。
Oh, my God. I love it. Did you like take down the podium like when football players are practicing and they have to like run really hard into the thing? You know what I mean? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Like they side swipe it, kind of spear it off the top of the thing is what you're thinking of.
讲台和校长。是的，我基本上就是讲台。你们有没有看过那些视频，我想这在南方更常见，在小联盟橄榄球赛中有一天，孩子们和他们的父母对抗，他们只是为了擒抱。这有点像传统。主要是妈妈们，是的。也有一些爸爸。
The podium out and the principal. Yeah, I was basically the podium. Have you guys ever seen those videos where like, I think it's a thing more in the South where there's a day in like peewee football where the kids go up against their parents and they're just for tackling. It's like kind of like a tradition. Mostly moms, yeah. There are some dads.
但孩子们穿着全套护具。所以他们就像……完全有缓冲，就像攀岩馆里的相扑一样，他们看起来滑稽地……然后就是父母，完全正确，父母只是直接把他们的孩子撞飞了，所以这只是他们的孩子在跑，他们跑过去，然后他们就爆炸了，但没人受伤，你就能感觉到那种宣泄和解脱，作为一个12岁男孩的妈妈，把他彻底平放在草地上，感觉太好了。等等，那是天才。我以为，我以为你要说的是孩子们要那样做，
But it's the kids are in full pads. so they're like absolutely cushioned like uh sumo at a you know climbing gym stuff they look like comically and then it's just parents exactly and the parents just themselves just smoke their kids like so it's just their kid running and they run and it just they explode but like nobody gets hurt and you just can sense the like catharsis in relief feel so good in being like the mom of a 12 year old boy, just absolutely laying him flat in the grid. Wait, that is genius. I thought, where I thought you were going was that the kids were going to do it,
父母都被包裹起来，孩子们去擒抱父母。你会以为所有的孩子脑子里都想的是，我要成为那个能把我爸爸打倒的人。就像我实际上，我踢橄榄球。他是个老头。然后每一个都被父母撞飞了，因为他们很大，你知道。珍妮，我觉得，我觉得我们应该听听肖恩对你本周难题的看法。
that the parents were all wrapped up and the kids get to tackle the parents. You would think all the kids have it in their head that they're like, I'm going to be the one that can take my own dad down. Like I'm actually like, I do football. He's an old man. And then every single one gets smoked by the parents because they're huge, you know. Jenny, I think, I feel like we should get Sean's like. input on your conundrum this week.
我不知道你进来时是否听到了一些，肖恩。我只听到了结尾。这是我的难题。这是一个新鲜的“我需要你们”，意思是，我向他们寻求帮助，那就是……你来月经了吗？它周六到期。你说“我来月经了”吗？
I don't know if you heard some of it as you were coming in, Sean. I just heard the tail end. Here was my conundrum. It was a fresh I need you guys, meaning I asked them for help with something, which was that... Did you have your period? It's due on Saturday. Did you say I got my period?
哦，好吧，是的。是的，我以为你需要帮助……卫生棉条？就像，你该怎么办？是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。你们会怎么处理？杯子？不，抱歉，抱歉，请继续。
Oh, well, yeah. Yeah, I thought you needed help with... Tampon? Like, what do you do? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. What would you guys deal? Cup? No, sorry, sorry, go ahead.
你有杯子吗？嗯，昨天白宫官方Instagram，我不知道，奇怪的是没关注，嗯，而且我根本不用我的Instagram。它就像我的Instagram，但三年前，我当时想，我真的完全不能和它互动。这对我不好。我知道我需要它，比如，当我进行单口相声巡演或播客或出书时，我穿了一件别人说你可以穿这个，但如果你穿了就最好发出来的衣服。那种事。不管怎样。昨天，白宫发布了一个表情包，就像《公园与游憩》里的莫娜·丽莎·萨珀斯坦，我参演的一部剧。我扮演莫娜·丽莎。所以那是我和亨利·温克勒。他扮演我爸爸。就像我的角色在说“钱，拜托”。他就像在给她钱。
Do you have a cup? Um, yesterday the White House official Instagram, which I am not aware of, uh, weirdly don't follow, um, and I don't use my Instagram at all. It is like my Instagram still, but three years ago, I was like, I actually can't interact with this at all. It's bad for me. I know I need to have it for like, when I have a standup toe or a podcast or a book coming out where I wear a dress that someone was like, you can wear this, but you better post it if you wear it. Like that kind of thing. Whatever. Yesterday, the White House posted, um, a meme that is like Mona Lisa. Saperstein from Parks and Recreation, a show that I was on. I played Mona Lisa. And so it's me and Henry Winkler. He played my dad. And it was like my character is saying like, money please. And he's like giving her the money.
但在我说“钱，拜托”的图片下方，一个动态图片，写着“非法移民”在说“钱，拜托”。然后在亨利下方，写着“民主党人”。我当时想，走吧。我感觉就像莫里斯·舍瓦利耶为纳粹唱歌什么的，但我没做这个。当然。是的。
But underneath the image of me saying money please, a moving image, it said illegal immigrants being like, money please. And then under Henry, it said Democrats. And I was like, go. I sort of felt like Maurice Chevalier singing for the Nazis or whatever, but I didn't do this. Sure. Yeah.
对，对，对，对。任何人，任何人如果不知道我的家庭，都知道那是什么。他实际上是我2025年在Apple Music上播放次数最多的。我喜欢电影《金粉世界》。那个特定的音乐会。好吧，你知道该怎么做，那就是什么都不做。你什么都不做。这就是你如何让它过去。
Right, right, right, right. Anyone, anyone know what that is if they don't know my family. He's actually my 2025 most played on Apple Music. I love the movie, Gigi. That's specific concert. Well, you know what to do, which is nothing. You don't do anything. That's how you just let it go.
我知道，因为当你成为那个被利用的人，为了什么，为了一个错误的信息或什么，而你是它的代言人，你忍不住会内化它让你感觉多么个人化，但要知道外面的每个人都明白这不幸是常态，这和你无关。你只是他们信息传递中的一颗棋子，
And I know because you feel when you're the person that the thing that is being exploited for whatever, for a missed message or whatever, and you're the kind of face of it, you can't help, but internalize how personal it makes you feel, but know that everybody on the outside understands that this is unfortunately the norm and it has nothing to do with you. You were just a pawn in their messaging,
而且我认为即使是共和党人，即使是民主党人，我认为每个人都会说，哦，这和珍妮无关，或者，或者，或者……哦，当然。亨利，对吧，你知道，嗯，但是……好吧，亨利……但我知道这很奇怪。不，我只是开玩笑。
and I think even Republicans, even Democrats, I think everybody goes, oh, it's nothing to do with Jenny or, or, or, um... Oh, for sure. Henry, right, you know, um, but... Well, Henry... But I know it's weird. No, I'm just kidding.
世界上最善良的人。最善良的。哦，天哪，我爱他们。我爱他们。但关于，你对压力有什么感觉？就像，对我来说，我当时想，哦，我不应该，首先我不应该回应这个，因为陷阱会起作用。就像，他们有，就像，一百万个陷阱来吸引任何人注意，这样我们就不会考虑投票权什么的。
The nicest man in the world. The nicest. Oh, God, I love them. I love them. But what about, What do you feel about the pressure? Like, for me, I was like, oh, I shouldn't, I shouldn't respond to this, first of all, because the trap will work. Like, they have, like, a million traps to just, like, suck in anyone for attention so that we're not thinking about voting rights or whatever.
但是，是的，麻疹。对。是的。你们能相信麻疹吗，伙计们？麻疹。天哪。马利斯·麻疹小姐。那个了不起的。
But, yeah, measles. Right. Yeah. Can you believe measles, you guys? Measles. Jesus Christ. The Marvelous Mrs. Measles. The marvelous.
是的。这就是谢丽尔·海因斯称呼自己的。该死。妈的。是的，这就是谢丽尔。谢丽尔·海因斯现在被叫的名字。
Yeah. That's what Cheryl Hines. calls herself. Fuck. Damn. Yeah, that's what Cheryl. Cheryl Hines is called now.
但是，你知道，世界上在这个国家里有A，有时间写恶心东西的人，和B，
But, you know, isn't it kind of amazing there are people in the world in this country that have A, the time to write nasty things and B,
有写恶心东西的倾向，这难道不令人惊讶吗？我的意思是，你没有，你的一天不忙吗？我的意思是，你不需要工作吗？是的。然后它为你做了什么，
the inclination to write nasty things. I mean, don't you have, isn't your day busy? Like, don't you have to work? Yeah. And then what does it do
去写这些坏东西。所以就像，是的，抓到他们了。然后他们继续一个小。我不知道。这只是，我从来没有，我从来没有在Instagram上写过任何坏话，就像关于任何人的任何事。我的意思是，只要给它。从喷泉里喝一口。
for you to just write these bad things. So like, yeah, got them. And then they go on a little. I don't know. It's just, I've never, I've never written anything bad on instant, like anything about anybody. I mean, just give it. Take a sip from the fountain.
你会想要的。是的。是的。渴望更多。好吧。是的。不管怎样。这就像爆米花。
You're going to want to. Yeah. Yeah. Thirsty for more. All right. Yeah. Anyway. It's like popcorn.
你不会只吃一个。我总是想象他们很忙，但我觉得有很多工作，有很多工作，有很多停机时间，我觉得该死，你的老板对你很刻薄，顾客很烂，去上面，我们通过匿名写一些刻薄的东西得到一点内啡肽冲击，就像它只是，我认为肖恩的建议是正确的，就是让它，这就是它，让它代谢掉，在社交媒体之外，还有像奇怪的、书呆子气的第二波，就像你会得到像《公园与游憩》明星珍妮·斯莱特说，是的，是的，你……
You're not just having one. I always imagine they are busy, but jobs that are, I feel like there's a lot of jobs where you got a lot of jobs where you got a lot of. downtime and I feel like damn sure your boss is mean to you a customer sucks go on there we get a little endorphin hit by writing something mean anonymously like it's just it's i think sean's advice is the right to just let it this is it and let it metabolize through and outside of social media there's also like the weird like dorky second wave of like you would get like parks and rec star jenny sleep tells yeah yeah what you're
白宫，你烂透了什么的。这只是下一个书呆子气的事情。这就像每个人都他妈的长大吧。他们叫我明星？我是一个，我做了。我没做几集。还有多少？因为我只看了你。
White House, you suck or whatever. It's just such a dorky next thing. It's just like everyone fucking grow up. They call me a star? I was a, I did. I didn't like five episodes. How many more were there? Because I only checked you out.
珍妮，我知道渴望，当有人对你做错事或有人对你撒谎时，渴望是如此强烈。我生命中确实有这样一件事，发生了一件事，它被夸大了，这个人完全、彻底地对我撒谎。不。而且是的，它变得越来越大，你所想做的就是展示收据，比如，我有这封邮件，我有这些课程评论，我有这个，那会……
Jenny, I know the desire to, the desire is so strong to when somebody does you wrong or somebody lies about you or whatever. There is this, there is this incident in my life where this one thing happened and it got blown out of proportion and this one person completely totally just lied about me. No. And yeah, and it was, it kind of grew and grew and all you want to do is show the receipts of like, I have this email and I have this course comments and I have this that would
摧毁这个人的生活，因为他们会，脸上无光。他们就像你刚才说的一切完全不对。但在我的律师、公关人员和朋友家人的建议下，伟大的建议，他们说，什么都不要做。我说，是的，但他们做的是错的。那是不对的。什么，就这样撒谎是不对的。他们说，不，不，不，不。
destroy this person's life in the sense that they would just be, have egg on their face. They're like everything you just said is completely not right. But on the advice and the great advice, of my lawyer and my publicist and friends and family, they were like, don't do anything. I'm like, yeah, but what they did was wrong. That's not right. What, that's not right to just go ahead and lie. And they're like, no, no, no, no.
我照做了。它仍然有点困扰我。是的。但那是正确的事情。是的。是的。是的。你知道，我收到短信时手上真的有生鸡肉。
And I did that. And it still kind of bothers me. Yeah. But it was the right thing to do. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You know, and I really had like raw chicken on my hands while I got the text.
就像我用指关节打开手机。我当时想，我女儿喜欢鸡腿。我腌了一整天。我永远，我永远不会猜到。天哪。她喜欢鸡腿。她就像疯了似的亚瑟王。她只是，我给她做了这些华丽的腌鸡腿。
Like I opened the phone with like my knuckle. I was like, my daughter loves a drumstick. I had marinated it all day. I'd never, I would have never guessed. Oh my God. She loves a drum stick. She's like freaking King Arthur. She just, I made her like these gorgeous marinated drumsticks.
你也吃了吗？我吃了。我感觉很好。我丈夫也吃了。但我做了一个浓汤，当我们昨天录制播客时，我想它可能在炉子上室温放得太久了。然后我重新加热了它。我晚餐大部分吃了那个。
Did you eat them as well? I did. And I felt great about them. So did my husband. But I had made a bisque that while we were recording our podcast actually yesterday, I guess it maybe it sat on the stove at room temp a little too long. And then I reheated it. And I mostly had that for dinner.
而且，当我这么说时，我该怎么说，我整晚都在腹泻？当然。可以说。别用暗语说话。别用暗语说话。可以说。你知道，就像，随你怎么翻译。我丈夫也病了，以至于今天早上我说，嘿。
And, like, when I say, how do I put this, I had diarrhea all night? Sure. So to speak. Stop speaking in code. Stop speaking in code. So to speak. You know, like, translate that how you will. My husband was also ill to the point where this morning I was like, hey.
他说，珍妮，昨晚我谷歌了一下。显然他谷歌了，什么是心脏病发作？不。因为他有非常严重的，比如，胃灼热和胀气。从牛腩里？不，是浓汤。是浓汤。是浓汤。
And he was like, Jenny, last night I googled. Apparently he Googled, what is heart attack? No. Because he had such bad, like, heartburn and gas. From the brisket? No, it was a bisque. It was a bisque. It was a bisque.
我，就像，让它变冷了。然后我重新加热了它。我想就是那个。因为我女儿没吃，她今天身体很好。所以不管怎样。你应该把它们结合起来，叫它“饼干”（Biscuit）。饼干。饼干。
I, like, let it get cold. Then I reheated it. I think that was it. Because our daughter didn't have it, and she's in great health today. So anyway. You should combine them and call it a biscuit. A biscuit. Biscuit.
哦，好吧。我喜欢这个。做吧。它让你既腹泻又胃灼热。它是饼干，但它一点也不像英国或美国的饼干。因为牛腩，饼干是我们最喜欢的菜肴之一，只是还没有名字，如果你要举办一个牛腩宴，你可以，你可以，你可以，你可以有一个牛腩宴，你可以有一个牛腩，它是你……
Oh, okay. I love this. Do that. It gives you both diarrhea and heartburn. It's a biscuit, but it's nothing like either the British or the American biscuit. Because the brisket, Biscuit is one of the bestc is one of, of our favorite um dishes there just hasn't been a name for it yet and if you're hosting a brisk you could you could you could you could have a brisk you could have a brisket where it is you
你做了一个牛腩宴，然后你有牛腩，新词，牛腩，是的，是的，然后我们得到，让我们更牛腩，然后你切掉婴儿阴茎的顶部，肖恩，在我们进入我们每周的观众问题之前，我们还没开始，发生了，不，不，我们没录音，我们中的任何一个，这只是一个追赶，所以感觉很自然，是的，现在开始，我想问你，因为你处于独特的地位，可以就此提供建议，我们需要它，你有什么建议关于如何让一段强大而长久的友谊在将其搬上荧幕并专业地纠缠在一起时更加繁荣，
did you do a brisk then you have the brisk it new word i t brisk it yeah yeah and then we get let's brisker and then you chop off the top of the baby's penis Sean before we get to our like the audience question we get each week we haven't started yet happened no no we're not recording any of us this right okay this is a catchup so it feels natural yeah start now I wanted to ask you because you're uniquely positioned to give advice on this and we need it do you have any tips on how to let a strong and long friendship flourish while putting it on the air and professionally entangling yourself even more,
即使它只是关于友谊。就像，你们做得很好。就像我不得不解释腹泻一样，我要把你的问题解释为我们如何在这所有的一切中保持朋友关系？是这样吗？是的。首先，你不需要离麦克风那么近说话，马克斯。其次，我在开玩笑。
even though it is just about the friendship. Like, you guys are doing fantastic. In the same vein that I had to interpret diarrhea, I'm going to interpret your question as how do we stay friends through all of this? Is that what it is? Yeah. First of all, you don't have to talk so close to the mic, Max. Second of all, I'm kidding.
在兄弟会，你就像，不，那是个好问题。嗯，事情是我们都住在同一个城市，即使我们不做播客，我们也经常一起玩。但我们也，我们确实像兄弟，就像你们是兄弟姐妹一样。当然我们吵过架。当然我们有，这只会让你更亲近，
At the frat first, you're like, No, that's a good question. Well, the thing is we all live in the same city and we all hang out even when we're not doing the podcast. But we've also, we really are like brothers and just like you guys are brothers and sister. Of course we've gotten in arguments. And of course we've got it just makes you closer
它让你更强大，让你们的纽带更紧密。你知道，所以我不会害怕，我相信你们也不会，因为你们认识很久了，去进行关于你们充满激情的议题的激烈讨论，你知道，你们度过了难关，在另一边，
and it makes you stronger and it makes your bond tighter. You know, so I wouldn't be afraid to, and I'm sure you guys aren't because you've known forever, to have heated discussions about topics you feel passionate about and you know and you get through it and on the other side
只是更亲密的关系，并不是说我们真的，我能想到一两次我们都陷入其中，那已经是几十年前的事了，谁赢了，绝对不是我。
is just a closer relationship and not that we have really I can think of like one or two times that we've all kind of gotten into it and that was like decades ago who won definitely not me
是的，你太……不，不，不，不，不，不，但那都是兄弟姐妹的事情，你知道，然后你意识到，哦，天哪，那太蠢了。是的，我们的动态有点更多的性张力。
yeah you're too no no no no no no but it was all it was all sibling stuff you know and then you realize oh god that was so dumb yeah Our dynamic is a little more sexual tension.
对。但不是你想的任何方向。你知道，盖比和我从Y2K开始就一直盯着对方看。是的。谁会先采取行动？你知道，像今天这样，我穿着高领毛衣和全长灯芯绒连体裤出现，你知道，这两个家伙都疯了。但你们玩得很开心，你们会永远做这个，对吧？
Right. But not in any of the directions you'd think. You know, Gabe and I have been staring at each other since Y2K. Yeah. Who's going to make the first move? You know, days like this when I show up in both a turtleneck and a full-length corduroy jumpsuit, you know, both of these guys are going crazy. But you guys are having a good time and you guys are going to do this forever, right?
而且就像，是的。我的意思是，真的，当我们上周面对面录音时，也许，我当时想，哦，我们做得越多，我就越有活力。我可以谈，我的意思是，我反正可以谈一整天。我有点这样做。有人在那里。走来走去，嘟囔着。我知道，我也是。
And it's like, yeah. I mean, truly like when we got to record in person, whatever last week maybe, I was like, oh, the more we do it, the more energized I get. I could talk, I mean, I could talk all day anyway. I kind of do. Someone there. Walking around, mumbling. I know, me too.
我告诉我的治疗师，你知道，她可以休息一下，因为我只是把一切都告诉了斯科蒂。是的。就像，我白天不停地说话。我就像，你觉得呢？哇，你看伯班克那些山。你觉得它们顶部曾经有雪帽吗？就像，无尽的蠢事。
I told my therapist, you know, that she gets a break because I just lay it all on, Scotty. Yeah. Like, I don't stop talking during the day. I'm like, what do you think? Wow, do you look at those mountains in Burbank. Do you think that like they ever had a snow cap on top of? Like, just endless. dumb shit.
珍妮没有梦，因为一切都在她醒着的时候处理了。什么都没剩下。那是真的。这就是我的治疗师告诉我的，为什么我的梦这么无聊。就像前几天我梦见我在参加SAT考试，我在等我的结果。这就是为什么它这么无聊。我在等三明治，或者，你知道，只是类似的东西。所以你在黑色空间里做梦。
Jenny doesn't have dreams because everything gets processed while she's awake. There's nothing left. That's true. That's what my therapist told me is the reason why my dreams are so boring. Like the other night I had a dream that I was taking the SATs and I was waiting for my result. The reason why it's so boring. I'm waiting for a sandwich or, you know, just stuff like that. So you dream in black space.
我白天处理得太多了，以至于当我该睡觉时，我的心理甚至想不出任何东西，所以它就像SAT。珍妮过去常在车里睡着，指着自己。那太奇怪了，那是什么意思？就像一种奇怪的尸僵，
I just processed so much during the day that when it's time for me to go to bed, it's like my psyche can't even think of anything so it's just like S-A-T. Jenny used to fall asleep in cars pointing at herself. It was such a weird like what does that mean? Like a weird rigor mortis
但也只是像一个奇怪的演员。我拔掉插头，但我还在这里，但是的，它完全是，那是什么意思？我不知道。我们在大学里去某个地方做即兴表演的路上，在一辆货车里。
but also just such like a weird like actor. I'm unplugging but I'm still here but yeah it just was fully what is that mean? I have no idea. We were in a van on the way to do an improv show somewhere in college.
那是很多次，但那可能是我开始尖叫的时候。哦，天哪。是的。是的。太好了。如果我后仰哪怕五度，我就出局了。没人睡觉。
It was many times but that was probably when I started screaming about it. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah. So good. If I recline even five degrees, I'm out. No one sleeps.
那发生过很多次，但那可能是我开始为此大喊大叫的时候。天哪。是啊。是啊。太棒了。如果我向后倾斜哪怕五度，我就睡着了。没人能睡得着。
Oh, really? No one falls asleep faster than me. It's crazy. If I, what about you, Max? I have to be put down like a wild horse. Yeah, you got to get shranked, right? Okay. Yeah, I'm, I'm Ambien and, you know, all sorts.
噢，真的吗？没人比我入睡更快了。太疯狂了。如果我，那你呢，马克斯？我得像野马一样被放倒才行。是啊，你得被“击昏”，对吧？好吧。是啊，我，我用安必恩（Ambien），还有，你知道的，各种药。
Yeah, yeah. Oh, that's good, though. It's great. Wow. Yeah. And, and you think you still need it? Ambien. you know whenever i like once a month try to take a night off and can but have like the worst night
是啊，是啊。噢，不过那挺好的。很棒。哇。是啊。而且，你觉得你还需要它吗？安必恩。你知道，每当我——比如一个月一次——尝试停药一晚，我能做到，但会度过最糟糕的一晚。
like wake up like i just you know cross the delaware by boat um messed up i have um messed up i have um so or something self-diagnosed yeah same and so if the second i watch a movie or tv show i'm out in like two minutes oh because i have to focus on something but then if i take that nap i'm up I can watch the whole thing. But it's just like the initial or reading a book, I'm like one, one paragraph. I'm out. We should take our voicemail, right? We have an audience question.
就像醒来时感觉自己刚，你知道，乘船横渡了特拉华河，嗯，一团糟，我有，嗯，一团糟，我有，嗯，所以或者某种自我诊断，是啊，我也是，所以只要我一看电影或电视节目，两分钟内我就睡着了，噢，因为我必须专注于某件事，但如果我小睡一会儿，我就醒了，我可以看完整个节目。但就像刚开始或者读一本书时，我读一段，一段。我就睡着了。我们该听听语音留言了，对吧？我们有个听众提问。
And Sean, we would love, people ask us for, you know, advice because we're, we have everything together. Figured out. And we're sage. I was going to call and leave one, leave a message. You should. You should. Please do.
还有肖恩，我们很乐意，人们向我们寻求，你知道，建议，因为我们，我们一切都处理得很好。想通了。而且我们是智者。我本来想打个电话留个言。你应该打。你应该打。请一定要打。
I should, yeah. Where should you point when you're sleeping? Yeah. Now you already know. That's a good one. My grandmother, Nana Connie, called the Boston Globe one time and told them they to do more more stories about that actress Jenny Slate. She really did.
我应该打，是啊。睡觉时你应该指向哪里？是啊。现在你已经知道了。这是个好问题。我祖母，康妮奶奶，有一次给《波士顿环球报》打电话，告诉他们要多写写那个女演员珍妮·斯蕾特的故事。她真的这么做了。
And then the reporter told me. Did you say my Anaconda? What did you show? My Nana Connie, my grandmother. Oh, Nanny Connie. And they were like, is this? Because they could see the caller ID. I love that.
然后记者告诉了我。你说的是我的“水蟒”（Anaconda）？你展示了什么？我的康妮奶奶，我祖母。噢，康妮奶奶。他们当时问，这是谁？因为他们能看到来电显示。我喜欢这个。
That's funny. And it says Jenny's Nana is what her color ID said. Okay, okay. Let's listen to this question from a listener. Hi, I just saw your post on Instagram, and here's my question. Is there any amount of nose picking that is acceptable in some kind of etiquette idea, idea of etiquette? I live in Colorado, and almost everyone here picks their nose because it is so dry, and you always have stuff going on. And then it's also an anxiety thing, and everybody's anxious.
真有趣。来电显示上写着“珍妮的奶奶”。好吧，好吧。让我们听听这位听众的问题。嗨，我刚看到你们在Instagram上的帖子，这是我的问题。在某种礼仪观念中，挖鼻孔到什么程度是可以接受的？我住在科罗拉多州，这里几乎每个人都挖鼻孔，因为天气太干燥了，你总是有东西要处理。而且这也是一种焦虑的表现，每个人都很焦虑。
And I would rather someone pick their nose than, like, do other bad things that come from anxiety. But when I see people really going at it or, like, cranking up their elbow, it really bugs me. And I cannot, I cannot tolerate it. And there's all kinds of things around that. Like, what do you do with what you get out of it, you know, out of your nose? Oh, yeah, what you do with what you get out of it. It's a beautiful. Put that on a month.
我宁愿别人挖鼻孔，也不愿他们做其他因焦虑而产生的坏事。但当我看到人们真的在用力挖，或者，比如，把手肘抬得很高时，这真的很困扰我。我无法，我无法忍受。这周围有很多事情。比如，你对挖出来的东西怎么处理，你知道，从鼻子里挖出来的东西？噢，是啊，你对挖出来的东西怎么处理。这太美妙了。把它写在月历上。
That's a great question. That's a great question. With what you get out of it. It feels like an inspirational saying. Or like a pillow. Yeah. But wait. So these are the high bra questions we got here.
这是个好问题。这是个好问题。关于你挖出来的东西。这听起来像是一句励志名言。或者像个枕头。是啊。但等等。所以我们这里得到的是这些高深的问题。
Yeah. Well, I mean, it's a pretty easy one. That was Dostoevsky herself calling in. Yeah. I don't know that it's easy. I don't think it's easy. Okay. Wait.
是啊。嗯，我的意思是，这是一个相当简单的问题。那是陀思妥耶夫斯基本人打来的。是啊。我不知道这是否简单。我不觉得这很简单。好吧。等等。
What's your answer? So I realized as I was listening to this question, there is something weirdly, I think, worse about working from the outside in than working on the inside. Does that make sense? What's that? Like a little pinch in the middle. A little pinch in the middle kind of feels like you're managing.
你的答案是什么？所以我意识到，当我听这个问题时，我觉得从外向内挖比在里面挖在某种奇怪的层面上更糟糕。这有道理吗？那是什么？就像中间捏了一下。中间捏一下感觉就像你在处理它。
But when you have the vaudeville hook. When you have the vaudeville hook. You can't have that. If you're working on something in the lobe, I don't even know what you call the larger. I'm like, well, that's gross. That's gross. Like the nostril, like if you're on like the side of the nostril,
但当你用杂耍钩子的时候。当你用杂耍钩子的时候。你不能那样。如果你在耳垂里处理什么东西，我甚至不知道你怎么称呼那个更大的部分。我心想，嗯，那太恶心了。那太恶心了。就像鼻孔，如果你在鼻孔侧面，
picking something. Weirdly in my head, I'm like I wouldn't do that in public. wouldn't want someone to see me in my car doing that. But it is an incredible feeling once you clear that out and you can breathe. Do you ever watch videos where they pull out massive amounts of mucus from noses? No. My mouthwaters. Yeah.
挖什么东西。奇怪的是，在我的脑海里，我觉得我不会在公共场合那样做。不想让别人在车里看到我那样做。但一旦你清理干净并且能呼吸了，那感觉真是太棒了。你看过那种从鼻子里拉出大量粘液的视频吗？没有。我流口水了。是啊。
It does. My mouthwaters are like, oh, God, that looks like it feels so good. The satisfaction of clearing out your nose. I mean, I've definitely seen people like going crazy on their noses in their own cars. and I understand that you know like there are people doing you know they're like popping temples and stuff because they feel that they're alone
确实。我流口水了，心想，噢，天哪，那看起来感觉一定很好。清理鼻子的满足感。我的意思是，我绝对见过人们在自己的车里疯狂地挖鼻子。我理解，你知道，就像有些人，你知道，他们在挤太阳穴之类的，因为他们觉得他们是独自一人的。
that's fine it's your car you know don't do it when someone else is in it but when you're free when you're out in the world I really well this is interesting I think because I think it's the car thing because people feel more confident because if if somebody sees you do it
那没关系，那是你的车，你知道，当有别人在车里时别那样做，但当你自由时，当你身处世界各地时，我真的，嗯，这很有趣，我想是因为车子的原因，因为人们感觉更自信，因为如果如果有人看到你这样做，
you're like fuck I don't care I'm going to drive away and never see this person again but if you do it you know in public or like in a in your house with other people watching, you're probably more discreet about it because you're stuck with that person in a room. Yeah.
你会想，去他的，我不在乎，我要开车走，再也不会见到这个人了，但如果你在公共场合，或者在你的房子里有别人看着时这样做，你可能会更谨慎，因为你和那个人困在一个房间里。是啊。
Oh, yeah. Of course. I don't know. What do you think about that? I have a gym membership just to pop in and absolutely rip ones in the locker room. You know, like I pay for it. And so I have a couple around the city.
噢，是啊。当然。我不知道。你怎么看？我办了健身房会员就是为了溜进去，在更衣室里彻底释放一下。你知道，就像我付了钱。所以我在这座城市有几个点。
And I'll just just park, get the validation, go to the locker room, absolutely get screwed up up there. And then just go. I was such a nose picker when I was little. Like, that was something I really had to like learn to like knack it off. Did you flick it or wipe it? I flicked it.
我就会去停车，验证一下，去更衣室，在那里彻底搞定。然后就走。我小时候是个挖鼻孔大王。就像，那是我真的必须学会戒掉的东西。你是弹掉还是擦掉？我弹掉。
Oh yeah. Yeah, I was a flicker. And I remember having to be like, okay, this is unacceptable to other people. I still think it's normal and fine. I think I knew not to let people see me doing it. But I do think it's really satisfying and that it's okay. It's your own body.
噢，是啊。是啊，我是个弹鼻屎的人。我记得我不得不告诉自己，好吧，这对其他人来说是不可接受的。我仍然认为这很正常，没问题。我想我知道不要让别人看到我这样做。但我确实认为这非常令人满足，而且没关系。这是你自己的身体。
You find a private space to do it. Like if you have like a dry bugger and getting it out, that feels great. I think the answer is you should really try to, well, this is what I would say. Try not to do it in public. Yeah. You know, just try. Just try. The etiquette is don't do it in public.
你找个私人空间去做。比如如果你有个干鼻屎，把它弄出来，感觉很棒。我想答案是你真的应该尝试，嗯，这就是我会说的。尽量不要在公共场合做。是啊。你知道，试着做。试着做。礼仪就是不要在公共场合做。
Don't do it. And definitely don't like it. Yeah. I'm sorry about Colorado's anxiety epidemic. I know it's tough to pick which brew house and pizza place to go to or whatever because there's four in every block. But you'll figure it out. I saw the clip the promo clip for I need you guys and Jenny you brought up such a funny thing about
不要做。绝对不要舔它。是啊。我很抱歉科罗拉多的焦虑流行病。我知道很难选择去哪家酿酒厂和披萨店，因为每个街区都有四家。但你会想通的。我看到了你们的宣传片，珍妮，你提到了一个非常有趣的事情，关于
getting your own phone or something you're like remember when you got your own phone it was such a big deal and Gabe you said and then your family would listen in or something Jenny's dad listened in yes all the time right my mom would do that too. I remember that as a kid. Like the landlines. And one time I went down to the basement and I called some gay chat group line. You know, remember those from the 1980s? Singles are waiting to party on the landline.
拥有自己的电话之类的，你说“还记得你拥有自己的电话时那是一件大事吗”，盖博你说“然后你的家人会偷听之类的”。珍妮的爸爸偷听，是的，一直都是这样，对吧？我妈妈也会那样做。我记得小时候那样。就像固定电话。有一次我下到地下室，拨通了一个同性恋聊天群的电话。你知道，还记得20世纪80年代的那些吗？单身人士在固定电话上等着聚会。
And you're like, oh, I'll try it. And I thought it was being real discreet. And then my mom got the, it was like $3 a minute or something. And then my mom got the phone bill. And she called it before confronting me. And she was like, what is this? And I was like, I don't know. I mean, I was like, I'm trying to call.
然后你会想，噢，我试试看。我以为我做得非常谨慎。然后我妈妈收到了，那是每分钟3美元之类的。然后我妈妈收到了电话账单。她在找我对质之前就打了那个电话。她问，这是什么？我说，我不知道。我的意思是，我说，我是在尝试给我的朋友兰迪打电话。
trying to call my friend Randy. Yeah. And I must dial the wrong number. And she was like, you dialed it five times for an hour, you know. But you could never get away with anything on a landline. No. God, no. No.
尝试给我的朋友兰迪打电话。是啊。我一定是拨错号码了。她说，你拨了五次，每次一个小时，你知道。但在固定电话上你永远无法逃脱任何事情。不。天哪，不。不。
Well, before caller ID, you could definitely prank call. You could do that. Star 69 or whatever. Yeah. Oh, that's right. You could block your number. You could block your number. So you could get away with anything.
嗯，在来电显示出现之前，你绝对可以恶作剧电话。你可以那样做。星号69之类的。是啊。噢，没错。你可以屏蔽你的号码。你可以屏蔽你的号码。所以你可以逃脱任何事情。
Can you do that on cell phones now? I don't know. I think so. I mean, there was a time when. I asking for a friend. Yeah, yeah. my friend Randy wants to know Randy needs to know if he can block
现在手机上能那样做吗？我不知道。我想可以。我的意思是，曾经有一段时间。我是替朋友问的。是啊，是啊。我的朋友兰迪想知道，兰迪需要知道他是否可以屏蔽
yeah because he likes to party on the phone jennie's phone rings with a block with a block number the number we knew about that we would call it like if we were like there was a pay phone somewhere and you could only listen to like 90 seconds before it made you paid um 1 800
是啊，因为他喜欢在电话上聚会。珍妮的电话响了，显示是屏蔽号码。我们知道那个号码，我们会打过去，比如如果我们当时在某个公用电话亭，你只能听90秒，然后它就会让你付费，嗯，1-800
red tits and what I don't know who like knew that but it's like also why is that why are not red nips Why are those, all the full titty's all red? They're all the red. The whole thing is red. The whole thing they're red.
红乳头，我不知道是谁知道那个，但就像，为什么是红乳头？为什么那些，所有的乳头都是红色的？它们全是红色的。整个东西都是红色的。整个东西，它们是红色的。
They're bright red. They're the same, because there's no change in tone. It's just an absolute fire engine. Oh, the, I once got a $750 AOL bill because I thought I had, and my parents were like, why do we have a $750 charge? And it was because I would, we had a second line that I quietly co-opted for AOL. And, but I didn't know that the 40 free hours had run. out or whatever because we would get those discs in the mail. Yeah.
它们是鲜红色的。它们是一样的，因为色调没有变化。它就像一个绝对的消防车。噢，我曾经收到过一张750美元的AOL账单，因为我以为我有，我父母问，为什么我们有750美元的费用？那是因为我会，我们有第二条线，我悄悄地把它挪用给了AOL。但是，我不知道那40个小时的免费时间已经用完了，或者其他什么，因为我们会收到那些邮寄来的光盘。是啊。
And truly it was because I would leave my computer on overnight to download like a dot jiff of like Tiffany Ambertheson, you know, like sitting on the hood of a Porsche, but it took 15 hours for like a half a megabyte file and cost my parents $800. Sorry, Mom. By the way, before we go, if you're looking for affordable plans for anything, smartless mobiles, $10 a month for 10 gigabytes. You're kidding. Thank you guys.
而且确实是因为我会整晚开着电脑下载像蒂芙尼·安伯·西森（Tiffany Amber Thiessen）的GIF图，你知道，坐在保时捷引擎盖上，但下载一个半兆字节的文件花了15个小时，让我父母花了800美元。对不起，妈妈。顺便说一句，在我们走之前，如果你正在寻找任何东西的实惠计划，Smartless手机，每月10美元，10GB流量。你在开玩笑吧。谢谢你们。
What a pleasure to be on your show. He's such a pro. Sean, thank you for coming on our show. It's so good to see you. I miss you. You too. I love you guys.
能上你们的节目真是荣幸。他真是个专业人士。肖恩，谢谢你来我们的节目。见到你真好。我想你。你也是。我爱你们。
I love you too. Oh, come on. Thanks. Thank you so much. Thanks for you. I love this so much. We do too. We let you.
我也爱你们。噢，别这样。谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢你们。我太喜欢这个了。我们也一样。我们让你。
I do. Okay. Bye. Bye. What an angel. That was so fun. I love Sean Hayes. He is one of one of the greats.
我喜欢。好吧。再见。再见。真是个天使。太有趣了。我爱肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）。他是最伟大的人之一。
I think that's the living room he or the room he was setting up in. At the beginning of a pandemic, like great bookshelf, great setup. Beautiful bookshelf. He also had a sort of a kitchen island moment too for table reads where you could see like a living room behind him. You're right. I don't know. I would suspect that you guys feel this, but like there are moments in, like, I don't feel that it's normal to be able to talk to Sean Hayes, you know, like.
我想那是他当时设置的客厅或者房间。在疫情开始时，很棒的书架，很棒的设置。漂亮的书架。他还有一个厨房岛台，用于剧本朗读，你可以看到他身后的客厅。你说得对。我不知道。我怀疑你们也有这种感觉，但就像，在某些时刻，我不觉得能和肖恩·海耶斯交谈是正常的，你知道，就像。
I know. Yeah. Like to be like, oh, yeah. Like look into my future and be like, yeah, I guess. to talk to one of the funniest people on TV. Yes. And he knows my name and, in fact, has, like, helped me have a podcast. That just was, like, kind of blowing my mind.
我知道。是啊。就像，噢，是啊。就像展望我的未来，心想，是啊，我想是吧。能和电视上最有趣的人之一交谈。是的。而且他知道我的名字，事实上，还帮助我做了播客。这简直让我感到震惊。
And I didn't want to say it to him because I felt like I would start crying. So I'll just tag it on the end here. But it's just, like, you know, remember that, like, episode of Will and Grace where it was, like, the real share? Of course. Oh, my God. Like, I just remember being, like, he's, like, a gold medalist of comedy. Jenny, that is crazy. Okay.
我不想对他这么说，因为我觉得我会开始哭。所以我只是把它加在最后。但这就像，你知道，还记得《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）里有雪儿（Cher）的那一集吗？当然。噢，天哪。就像，我只记得当时心想，他是喜剧界的金牌得主。珍妮，那太疯狂了。好吧。
I, so Daniel and I, my husband and I, we've rewatched the old Will and Grace many times over our 10-year mayor. So like, and he always makes fun of me because while we're watching it, I will mumble under my breath. Olympic level. Oh my God. Olympic level. Whenever Sean lands a joke, it's just like. It's crazy. The writing is hard to say that character is like hard to play.
我，所以丹尼尔和我，我丈夫和我，我们在我们10年的婚姻中重温了老版《威尔与格蕾丝》很多次。所以，他总是取笑我，因为当我们看的时候，我会喃喃自语。奥林匹克级别。噢，天哪。奥林匹克级别。每当肖恩抛出一个笑话，它就像。太疯狂了。剧本很难说，那个角色很难演。
And then he was doing like backflips and all this physical stuff. Absolutely crazy. Like sometimes, like the first time I went to, like, a table read for a show and was like, oh, you, like, I didn't really know what it was. Like, get what, so if you don't know, like, if you're on TV, there used to be a time. They don't really do it a lot now, but it used to be, especially on, like, a sitcom, but also animated stuff. Before they would film or record, you would all sit around, like, a table and everybody would, like, perform the script. And, like, for the executives and you would, like, really want people to laugh and, like, see if it works. And it was kind of a lot of pressure.
然后他还在做后空翻和所有这些身体动作。绝对疯狂。就像有时，我第一次去参加一个节目的剧本朗读，心想，噢，你，我真的不知道那是什么。就像，明白什么，所以如果你不知道，如果你在电视上，曾经有一段时间。他们现在做得不多了，但过去常有，特别是在情景喜剧上，还有动画片。在他们拍摄或录制之前，你们都会围坐在一张桌子旁，每个人都会表演剧本。而且，为了高管们，你真的会希望人们笑，看看它是否有效。那压力有点大。
And it was really important. And anyway, the first time I did one, the thing I thought, and it was a successful table read, on my way out, I was like, oh, my God, the people that got to see Sean Hayes and Megan Malalley do table reads must have, like, been crying. Like, they must have, like, known that they were, like, a part of something. One story I meant to tell earlier, just to wrap it up to let you know how, where I am, as we head off into our days, is that you were talking, you mentioned. We were sadly talking about ICE. You mentioned Dean Cain, Jenny. Yeah. And a month ago, I was looking at my phone.
而且这真的很重要。总之，我第一次做的时候，我当时想到的，那是一次成功的剧本朗读，在离开的时候，我心想，噢，天哪，那些能看到肖恩·海耶斯和梅根·莫拉莉（Megan Mullally）进行剧本朗读的人一定在哭。就像，他们一定知道他们是某件事的一部分。我之前想讲的一个故事，为了总结一下，让你知道我现在的状态，当我们开始新的一天时，就是你刚才提到的。我们很遗憾地谈到了ICE。你提到了迪恩·凯恩（Dean Cain），珍妮。是啊，一个月前，我正在看手机。
And I said to my wife, oh, wow, Trader Vicks is reopening in West Hollywood. And she's like, what Trader Vicks? And I, like, love, like, teaky cocktails and love kind of like L.A. divey spots. And so I started explaining to her. I was like, well, it was kind of this, like, now there's a lot of them. But it was sort of this hot spot in, like, I think the 50s, 60s. And it was like, you know, Dean Martin and his. his crew would be there.
我对妻子说，噢，哇，Trader Vicks要在西好莱坞重新开业了。她说，什么Trader Vicks？我，就像，喜欢提基鸡尾酒，喜欢洛杉矶那种破旧的地方。所以我开始向她解释。我说，嗯，它曾经是那种，现在有很多这样的店。但它在50年代、60年代左右是那种热门地点。而且就像，你知道，迪恩·马丁（Dean Martin）和他的团队会在那里。
It was sort of like, you know, Dean Martin's hang, but I accidentally said Dean Kane. So she was like, I'm excited about Trader Vicks. She's like, what's Trader Vicks? I was like, it's a sort of like teaky lounge, like where Dean Kane used to hang out. And it was kind of like Dean's crew. But I'm saying she, but she,
它有点像，你知道，迪恩·马丁的聚会场所，但我意外地说成了迪恩·凯恩。所以她说，我对Trader Vicks很兴奋。她说，Trader Vicks是什么？我说，这是一种提基酒廊，就像迪恩·凯恩过去常去的地方。而且它有点像迪恩的团队。但我说她，但她，
and to her credit was just like, oh, cool. Yeah. I would be like pretty excited about a restaurant where Dean Kane used to hang out. Yeah. Reopening, famously his crew of lounge lizards. The coolest. Yeah, the coolest. And coming up next, Dean Cain will be batching up some teaky drinks.
而且值得称赞的是，她只是说，噢，酷。是啊，如果迪恩·凯恩过去常去的餐厅重新开业，我会非常兴奋的。是啊，他那群著名的酒廊蜥蜴团队。最酷的。是啊，最酷的。接下来，迪恩·凯恩将调制一些提基饮料。
Riding in here on a big old lounge lizard. He's sitting on one of the big stegosaurus spikes. This was fabulous, you guys. Yeah, it really was. Gosh, I love you guys so much. And is there anything cool you're going to do before you see us all next? I'm going to send the White House some memes. Oh, we're taking our baby to a pumpkin to like a big light show at the skin.
骑着一只老酒廊蜥蜴进来。他坐在其中一个巨大的剑龙尖刺上。这太棒了，伙计们。是啊，确实如此。天哪，我太爱你们了。在下次见到我们之前，你们有什么酷的事情要做吗？我要给白宫发一些表情包。噢，我们要带我们的宝宝去参加一个南瓜灯展，在斯坎索花园（Canso Gardens）今晚，南瓜，万圣节。是的。我们可能会给他穿上他的服装。哇。是的，你应该这样做。那太好了。那太好了。我会发照片。
Canso Gardens tonight, Pumpkins, Halloween. Yes. We might dress him up in his costume. Wow. Yes, you should. That's so nice. That's so nice. I'll send picks.
哇。再见，伙计们。再见。我需要你们。这个节目叫《我需要你们》（I Need You Guys）。由我们，盖博·利德曼（Gabe Liedman）、珍妮·斯蕾特（Jenny Slate）和马克斯·西尔维斯特里（Max Silvestri）主演。这是Smartless Media的制作。《我需要你们》由安·哈里斯（Anne Harris）、乔希·里士满（Josh Richmond）和德文·托里·布罗姆（Devin Tory Brom）制作。
Wow. Bye guys. Bye. I need you girls. This show is called I Need You Guys. And it starred us, Gabe Leadman, Jenny Slate, and Max Silvestri. It's a production of Smartless Media. I Need You Guys is produced by Anne Harris, Josh Richmond, and Devin Tori, Brom.
由乔希剪辑。音乐由德文创作。执行制片人是世界上最酷的人，盖博、珍妮和马克斯。Smartless Media的执行制片人是威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）、杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）、肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）、理查德·科森（Richard Corson）和伯尼·卡明斯基（Bernie Khaminsky）。请发送电子邮件至 INeedYouGuysShow@gmail.com，告诉我们你所有最令人困惑的礼仪问题，或者更好的是，拨打949-1-21-21，留下你的问题作为语音留言，这样我们就可以在节目中播放你们可爱的声音。我们下周见，因为我们需要你们。我们需要你们。我们需要你们。
and edited by Josh. Music is by Devin. Executive producers are the coolest people in the world, Gabe, Jenny, and Max. Executive producers for Smartless Media are Will Arnett, Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, Richard Corson, and Bernie Khaminsky. Email us at I Need You Guys Show at gmail.com with all your most perplexing etiquette questions, or even better, call us at 949-1-21-21 and leave your questions as if voicemails so we can play your adorable voices on the show. We'll see you next week, because we need you guys. We need you guys. We need you guys.
我们需要你们。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
We need you guys. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们需要你们。这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。